[Music]
so there was an amazing documentary
called flight from death which distilled
the human condition down to its bare
bones unbearable awareness of mortality
like that is the agitation of mankind
and the production company that made the
film is called transcendental media and
they actually say that their slogan is
to agitate the sleep of man what does
this hint well it hints at a kind of
calling and hints at a kind of
responsibility to people that make films
people that encode the human experience
to create narratives that imbibe
themselves and Incept themselves in our
minds to provide context for who and
what we are the storytellers are the
ones that craft a narrative then awaken
the minds attention from the lethargy of
custom is called reduced to say and
instead of directed towards the wonders
of existence again to agitate the sleep
of mankind and today we live in a world
where everybody makes media everybody
shares media the barriers of entry have
been lowered all of us now have
responsibility then to output content
that reflects the best of the human
condition
if media is a drug are we going to
create a narcotic drug that stupefies
its audio
mindless entertainment or are we going
to treat media as an infield genic that
dissolves boundaries that trans figure
Eight's modalities of thoughts perhaps
this is the kind of media that we
shouldn't celebrate
media that agitates many of it
transforms meaning that inspires because
again to agitate the sleep of mankind
should be all of our goals hey guys we
want to take a look at shots of awe
behind-the-scenes how it all comes to
life we'll to check out this episode of
shot on seeker stories which explores my
daily rituals and how we make shots of
[Music]